black edition sommeil
je le fais
à ses côtés
il aime chacun d'entre eux quatre ils
méditent et de sa fille dont il a tu es
tu vas révélation c'est pas facile ce
qu'elle fait parce que c'est super tout
simplement que l'amérique est
moi je vais
de nous faire j'avais oublié tout en
vous faisant tout le temps oublié sa
confiance que je vous raconte
vrai quand vous verrez le film à sortir
[Musique]
cet automne le 22 septembre prochain
voyez aussi il ya son fils qu'il a aux
[Musique]
jeunes mais nous sommes encore qu'à sa
tête
meyer a plus petits rôles d'anti mais je
vais en fils aussi
[Musique]
regardez là c'est tout acabit peine que
vous voyez
[Musique]
allez
les enfants sont ce sont ceux qui jouent
les rôles du fret a third
les flashbacks défis et univers vocal et
là aussi j'ai dit à mes yeux c'est
indigne a écrit le roman son histoire
qui aura compté
[Musique]
mystic river
e
pas évident de savoir que dit la vérité
une actrice aussi forte en ce pas parce
qu'elle est enfant d'acteurs et
d'actrices aussi puisqu'elle est
automatiquement une crise c'est très
motivant
côté du métal ne fait pas de vous des
métallurgistes ça n'a rien à voir avec
ça c'est c'est cet autre chose
elle a un truc elle a vraiment vraiment
un truc quand vous verrez film vous le
saurez bien la prison tant elle a 30 ans
elle explose vraiment dans ce film là
elle et elle est vraiment étonnant
vraiment étonnante
[Musique]
c'est parce qu'on pique non plus à l'été
même en deux
les sélectionne dix films indépendants
et à quelques années
[Musique]
vous entendez là je
mes chansons du film des chansons du
film sheitan appelé ses copains qui
s'est passé par exemple dit m
voilà et le chanteur de pearl jam pardon
qui lui a composé d'autres sources ont
le sourire comme il l'avait fait pour
into the wild si vous vous souvenez
et voilà on revient à filtrer
icahn a alors on est en plein american à
on est dans des traversées d'une heure
l'amérique
le son
lui le fils c'est bien il fait avec
juste la célébration de l'amérique de
ceux qui sont un petit peu laissé sur le
côté mais qui ont envie de rentrer
l'artiste aime à l'origine pour ne pas
trouver sa place dans ce système a été
un échec
[Musique]
il a le sens du film
son regard du tri plus ouvert a peur de
décevoir
sa fille par appel si vous êtes parent
terre si vous étiez pas de quoi très
sensible
vous n'êtes pas ne pas être sensible à
sophie poux pas rester insensible à ce
statut
m
[Musique]
evra
catherine médical images
[Musique]
venir
avec son réalisateur chatel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quatre éliminés qu'ils jouent
merde douadi l'admettre dans l'île
ma fille est partie à l'époque
présent dans les flash banni et
maquillés pour la partie contemporaine
et attend pas et encore des photos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc j'appelle
vient à cannes
[Musique]
pas du tout en 91 y présente à la
quinzaine son premier film en tant que
réalisateur d indian runner
il est revenu en compétition en tant
qu'acteur il ya remporté le prix
d'interprétation masculine
pour le film de nick cassavetes schiste
doivent lice était en 1997 il revient en
compétition en 2001 en réalisateur avec
the pledge il présenté à oui un type
plus beau des rallyes descente a thief
dans le mythique birds éthiques
[Applaudissements]
c'était l'un de ses deux oscars le
second c'était pour le milk de gus van
sant
oh
le premier c'était en 2003 pour mystic
river le deuxième en 2009 jeu
comme toujours car chanter
l'omx ap ap by tout en français je pense
que vous avez compris
ensuite il est revenue re compétition
pourquoi petits rôles vertou tir dans
what just happened de barry levinson
il y a eu aussi fair game avec naomi
watts le film de doug liman en 2010 bien
sûr tree of life en 2011 7 10 ans après
vidéo
on l'a vu aussi en compétition dans this
must be the place et film de paolo
sorrentino
c'est en 2000
aussi la fois qu'on l'a vu ici c'était
génial maintenant cinq ans de la space
en 2016 et le voilà de retour
en famille avec sa fille
100 spectateurs
dil alten et catherine musique que l'on
voit les grands sans oublier bien sûr
qu'il était président du jury en 2008 a
remis la palme d'or au film de laurent
cantet entre les murs et voilà donc
l'accueil
21' le monde
il y aller
ap
sa fille et actrice dylan et de
catherine munich
[Musique]
m
ouais je pense qu'il est en train de
dire à dylan c'est ce que voulait
vérifier très heureuse qu'il avait envie
de lui dire on va dire ça en intérieur
peu mais bon j'ai pas de questions ça va
laisser du temps
[Musique]
et voilà donc
chaque pen entouré de catherine munich
et de dylan m
i marsh qui salue la foule et du monde
en corée pour tout le monde sur la
croisette
sur les côtés pour des raisons que vous
connaissez
c'est loin d'un petit peu
[Musique]
les photographes
masqué qui regarde
3 le quatuor d'avoir une bonne photo ça
sent là c'est trop tard monsieur
mais je ne fous
ah non il encore une chance regarder
puisqu'il se retournant aux démarches
pour une dernière photographie
[Musique]